our ballpark will be one of the finest
minor league stadiums in the country it
will be the game changer in the region
because this is what's going to help
turn Hartford around and it's clearly
the kind of big bet that we make any
time you arrive at the intersection of
government real estate developers always
something worth writing about
it just one and a hydride blasted it's
deployed Tabares back to the track it's
gone the rock cats with a walk-off home
run in the final ever game at new
British Stadium and like a late inning
home run the rock hats were gone for 32
years New Britain Connecticut stubble a
minor league team was an assembly-line
for some of the greatest talent the game
of baseball has ever seen
Roger Clemens started out playing for
New Britain so did Curt Schilling Jeff
Bagwell Torii Hunter's and David Ortiz
all kicked off their big league careers
in the small city of New Britain and
right up until the day the team packed
its bags and left New Britain for nearby
Hartford their fans kind of liked it I
would go beyond liked I would say they
were loved you know they're very popular
with families I have two two children
myself and we often went down there well
it came out of nowhere they were
stealing the team from New Britain which
which didn't seem like a good idea the
team were looking for a more modern
stadium more modern facility and they
didn't see that they could get that in
New Britain the mayor had taken this
initiative basically as I understand it
on his own the purpose of this press
conference is to welcome the rock cats
to Hartford we kind of sprung it on the
city saying you know we're gonna do this
he paid a lot of money for what was a
horribly inadequate study that was
basically misrepresented entirely what
in fact bringing a minor league team to
Hartford would do so the City Council
commissioned Fred Carstensen to help
produce a new study Carstensen projected
an entirely new neighborhood from
scratch three hundred and fifty million
dollars in development with hundreds of
residential units a brewery a
supermarket with the ball park at the
center of it all it would be the biggest
development Hartford had seen in decades
but it came with one big condition in
order to protect the city financially
they had to get the whole
enchilada they had to get the whole
development that the stadium by itself
would not generate sufficient economic
activity even under the best-case
scenario they're hoping that it will
create jobs that people who go to the
stadium will patronize other parts of
the city the the downtown and in turn
help increase the tax base when you've
got all the pieces in place you know
then they come out ahead not by a lot I
mean this is not some kind of a big win
but the question was how do you protect
the city from the point of view of being
able to cover the cost of the stadium
over the 20 year time horizon to pay off
the bus once the city council signed on
to the ballpark there was one last
obstacle parked in the way of
construction three acres of privately
owned parking lots stood where the
ballpark was supposed to be the city
couldn't reach an agreement with the
owners to buy the land so instead of
making a deal they paid the owner two
million dollars in compensation and
seized 14 properties under eminent
domain
recently there has been some discrepancy
they have found cost overruns and to the
tune of 10 million in order to finish
the stadium instead of 56 million
dollars they need 66 million dollars
they mean 10 million dollars more when
the Hartford City Council approved this
we said the budget was maximum of 56
million the headline here is that we're
not going to spend a penny more than 56
million
or else the team owners gonna pay for it
or the developer the City Council kind
of said that to the taxpayers we're not
gonna put any more money in because when
this was first proposed it was some
opposition to it you know from the
taxpayers Hertford officials and leaders
are always saying we don't have enough
money and the idea of spending 56
million dollars on a stadium won at the
same time you're saying we don't have
money for our schools but we don't want
enough money for social services or all
the other things we do in Hartford it's
just law enforcement and then saying but
we do have 56 million dollars for
baseball stadium that start people as in
Congress and just not sound public
policy this team is ready for the tough
task ahead enter Luke bronan hartford's
new mayor tasked with fixing the ten
million dollar shortfall and getting the
stadium back on track
as the mayor negotiated with the
developer and the team owner
construction crews raced to finish the
ballpark before the start of the
baseball season they worked all day and
at night but with opening day just four
months away
Hartford waited to see if it would have
a stadium in time for baseball season
people are watching
what's it like to do business in
Hartford and when there's a ten million
dollar shortfall on a fifty six million
dollar plan it sends a it sends a bad
message about the ability of the city to
get things done but just as confidence
reached a low point the development
began a late inning rally my message
start for taxpayers is we're trying to
get the best result out of a difficult
situation first mayor bronan struck a
deal with the team of the developer in
the city to split the ten million dollar
cost and bring the stadium to completion
and businesses were getting on board the
developer is talking to a grocery store
they recently announced that the Hard
Rock Cafe wants to bring a hotel here
today the Hard Rock Corporation
announced plans to build a Hard Rock
Hotel in Hartford the new hotel will be
built in the downtown north neighborhood
right near the new ballpark the public
policy and public investment reshapes
the market environment and markets are
phenomenal at generating lots of you
know really beneficial outcomes but
sometimes and in fact historically the
public sector plays a really really
critical role in unleashing the private
sector why should the people of Hartford
many of whom are very very poor
why should this burden be placed on them
it strikes me as as you know morally a
pretty clear answer and that is it
shouldn't be the stadium itself is about
a month behind and initially the team is
going to have to play all of its games
away and obviously that's not what you
want because that's not going to
generate any of the benefits that are
anticipated with Dunkin Donuts Park
missing the first 52 games of the season
some hope they could strike a deal to
return to their old ballpark back in New
Britain but that wasn't going to happen
because New Britain found a team of
their own to fill the old ball park the
bees are landing in New Britain it's
Connecticut's knew his face ball team
the new team has a name
just like the rock cats were lured away
from New Britain you've written lured
the bees away from their previous
Stadium in Camden New Jersey built only
15 years ago taxpayer-subsidized
Campbell's field was the centerpiece of
an economic revitalization campaign for
a struggling city but the predicted
stadium attendance and revenues fell
short and hopes for development never
materialized abandoned by its team
Campbell's field today spends most of
the year empty and unused Campbell's
field is the worst-case scenario for
Hartford and while regional studies make
a hopeful case for Dunkin Donuts park a
host of national studies have concluded
that Campbell's field is closer to the
norm there are a lot of unknowns right
now I mean studies have said that yes
this is going to be a benefit
economically to the city you know
there's gonna be jobs that are going to
be created the hope for spillover into
the rest of downtown but that is yet to
be seen